ce mardi 24 septembre se tenait le forum
de la création d'entreprise un événement
co organisé par saint quentin en
yvelines et la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines
nous sommes avec othman nassr ou bonsoir
bonsoir le dise président en charge du
développement économique sur saint
quentin en yvelines alors déjà première
question sur la création d'entreprise en
quoi c'est une thématique stratégique
pour saint quentin en yvelines
on est sur un territoire sacré en
yvelines qui est particulièrement
dynamique et un des poumons économiques
de l'île de france
il est important naturellement qu'on
accompagne tous les créateurs pour créer
les emplois de demain
c'est d'abord souvent des emplois pour
ceux qui créent leur entreprise qui
décide entre guillemets de se mettre à
leur compte et puis ça permet de créer
aussi de nouveaux emplois vous donne un
seul chiffre parmi les entreprises que
nous accompagnons ici à saint quentin en
yvelines
80% d'entre elles créent au bout de deux
ans plus de deux emplois donc c'est
vraiment la thématique de l'emploi
la bataille de l'emploi qui justifie
qu'on ait aujourd'hui ce bel événement à
saint quentin en yvelines et puis
surtout ce toute cette stratégie à la
fois régionale et saint-quentinoise pour
la création d'entreprise c'est
complémentaire à l'attractivité de
d'autres entreprises pour qu'elles
viennent s'installer sur le territoire
finalement bien sûr on a des grands
comptes
ici à saint quentin en yvelines qui ont
besoin de sous traitants qui ont besoin
d'un tissu de pme de tpe dynamique on a
des thématiques des filières entières je
pense par exemple à la cyber sécurité
sur lesquelles on arrive à faire
travailler ensemble aujourd'hui des
grands comptes comme airbus des
entreprises de plus petite taille qui
sont installés dans notre incubateur le
ski cube
et puis et puis des opérateurs de
travaux publics sur tout ce qui touche
par exemple avec les rage on a fait une
expérimentation là dessus donc on a
besoin de créateur d'entrepreneurs de
repreneur en même temps qu'on a besoin
des grands comptes qui sont déjà
installés à saint quentin en yvelines et
qu'on espère bien garder je le disais
vous avez organisé le premier forum de
la création d'entreprise sur saint
quentin en yvelines je crée ma boîte un
premier bilan de cet événement bd je
crois que c'est à grand succès on avait
plus de 450 inscrits on a une vingtaine
de conférences et d'ateliers différents
on remercie d'ailleurs nos partenaires
et je pense notamment la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie quitte à nos
côtés dans ce don ce bel événement je le
disais ça permet de renforcer et
d'autres en appui aux créateurs
d'entreprise on a accompagné ces trois
dernières années plus de 1000 créateurs
d'entreprise à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est colossal et cet événement et pays
participent à la force de la prise de
conscience que l'entrepreneuriat est un
sujet majeur
heures qui se développe qui s'est
beaucoup développée ces dernières années
et qui va être probablement encore en
plein développement dans les années à
venir et que saint quentin en yvelines
fournit un écosystème favorable à la
création d'entreprise et puis on le voit
bien aujourd'hui avec ce forum par les
intervenants les ateliers et les trente
exposants qui sont à nos côtés
aujourd'hui pour accueillir tous les
créateurs qui ont un projet d'entreprise
concrètement comment vous accompagner
ses créateurs d'entreprises ces porteurs
de projets alors il y a plusieurs outils
on a d'abord un incubateur le ski cube
qui correspond à un investissement fort
de l'agglomération pour accueillir les
projets les plus innovants on a une
pépinière d'entreprises promo paul qui
vient aussi fournir un ensemble de
services de bureau et de services
mutualisés à moindre coût pour les
entreprises
on a bien l'accompagnement qui est
fourni encore une fois par les services
de l'agglomération voit aujourd'hui avec
ce forum avec la vingtaine de
conférences et d'ateliers mais on le
voit tout au long de l'année
on a organisé 95 événements différents
ces trois dernières années sur cette
thématique de la création d'entreprise
donc il ya un écosystème qui favorable
je pense aussi à des événements comme le
ski business day qui permet à plus de
600 entreprises de se rencontrer pour
des rendez vous d'affaires
là aussi c'est un rendez vous très
plébiscité qui aura lieu en novembre
prochain tout à fait car donc bientôt
lieu
eh bien vous aviez qu'on a ainsi toutes
les briques toutes les composantes des
biens pour avoir un environnement les
plus dynamiques pour la création
d'entreprise les plus favorables aux
créateurs d'entreprise probablement de
toute la région ile de france
vous êtes aussi acteur dans le
financement des entreprises parce que la
création d'entreprise c'est forcément
synonyme de financement et d'avoir des
fonds accessibles pour lancer son projet
bien sur l'accompagnement sur le fond
des sujets sur les thématiques par
exemple de ressources humaines
on a aussi une plateforme et racheta
dessus sont des sujets importants mais
le nerf de la guerre c'est évidemment le
financement et là dessus on a notre
fonds initiative saint quentin qui et
qui très performant qui accompagne
beaucoup de créateurs d'entreprise c'est
un million d'euros de prêts qui sont
débloqués par ce fonds pour accompagner
une cinquantaine de projets donc c'est
absolument considérable et je le dis
d'ailleurs pour que tout le monde soit
bien au courant s'il y a des créateurs
ou des repreneurs d'entreprises qui
souhaitent être accompagnés
financièrement et bien signe à ses prêts
d'honneur qui viennent compléter et
servir aussi de levier au financement
bancaire pour rendre ces projets de
création d'entreprise les plus tangibles
possible et leur permettre aussi d'être
de permettre un vrai succès
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure la
création d'entreprise emmène des
créations d'emploi mais parfois aussi
c'est des créateurs d'entreprise qui se
créent eux mêmes leur emploi parce que
parfois ils sont demandeurs d'emploi
bien sûr on a ici à sa gratte on y vit
l'un des taux de chômage les plus bas
d'île de france on a à peu près 8 5%
elle néanmoins il reste toute une partie
de la population ça continue à ce qu'ils
aimeraient créer sa propre entreprise ou
qui est exclue du marché du travail et
c'est en plus de l'offre de formation
que nous débloquons c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on a fait et bien ce qu'on appelle le
campus du numérique avec 300 places de
formation qualifiante dans les métiers
du numérique qui sont en tension et mais
ça permet aussi à des gens de découvrir
des métiers dans lesquels il y a des
possibilités de créer sur l'entreprise
et c'est particulièrement le cas dans la
filière numérique et ça aussi c'est
quelque chose dont on est très fiers ici
à saint quentin de permettre à ceux qui
le souhaitent de créer leur propre
activité
pour conclure un chiffre ce sont les
données de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie d'île de france
dix huit mille entreprises créées ces
douze derniers mois dans les yvelines un
commentaire sur ce chiffre c'est un
record
c'est un record est une tendance
d'ailleurs qu'il est pas propre aux
yvelines mais on est sur une forte
création d'entreprises ces dernières
années en particulier dans les villes et
à saint-quentin puisque encore une fois
on a une région un territoire
particulièrement dynamique mais ça
montre aussi qu'on est en train de
changer aussi d'époque et qu'il ya une
volonté de beaucoup de gens sur des
parcours plutôt d'indépendants de
freelance de créateurs d'entreprise à ça
prend des facettes très différente eh
bien je crois que le rôle d'une
collectivité c'est ce qu'on fait à saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est d'accompagner ce mouvement parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on préparera aussi
et bien les emplois de demandes
merci othman natrue merci à vous vice
président en charge du développement
économique à saint quentin en yvelines